hi my name is Kate McKinnon I'm shooting  here with GQ magazine the cats I shot  with today were talking [ __ ] about each  other different people they had shot  with they told me secrets about people  that I care yeah they were really just  [ __ ]  they have scenes and things those cam  the funniest person you've never heard  of is my personal cat Nino I guess  that's a cat that's not a person my  comedy Idol growing up with Catherine  O'Hara in all of the Christopher Guest  movies and also Molly Shannon and on the  gasteyer and Cheri Oteri on Saturday  Night Live you've heard of it I've  kissed a lot of men on the show the best  kisser is Aidy Bryant we had we have to  kiss in a sketch on the season finale of  season 40 and it wasn't really kissing  it was more of just like pressing our  faces together like that but that meant  the most what the other guys were good  too  you